is russia helping china build nuclear  weapons or give them any supplies they  have been the the the uh the whole and  this is one of the thing reasons i think  we'd be able to do a deal with putin  because i think he's russia  not just putin  they're probably disappointed in uh in  in and and what they've gotten back from  china because uh china went from  pretty much a militarily backward  country you know that we weren't all  that concerned about  but in a couple of decades they've been  built into a pure competitor with the  united states both with conventional  forces  modern navy modern army modern air force  and now they've got uh you know modern  nuclear weapon systems and all of this  has been built  on technology that's been stolen from  the united states but also technology  that they've gotten from russia in fact  some of the most important stuff is  russian supply technology for both  conventional and nuclear forces